so just talk us through what happened
you know you're you're in Qatar as well
as first match you're in your hotel room
or wherever you're staying getting ready
for the match and you of course put on
your bucket hat
yeah well Buddha good morning first of
all Sophie yes I mean look I think the
first thing to say is it wasn't just me
that was in that predicament I mean I've
had a louder voice because of my role
here I'm an ambassador for Wales for the
Football Association of Wales and the
Welsh government so I guess I've had a
bigger platform
but there were others in the same
position there were several friends and
colleagues of ours who'd been uh who'd
had their hats removed and confiscated
or indeed in a couple of cases thrown in
the bin which is pretty insulting and of
course the the reality is we we were
told by FIFA before the tournament that
rainbow attire and rainbow symbols would
be permitted inside the stadiums quite
rightly so too so to be perfectly honest
I hadn't really thought that there would
be any kind of issue with entering the
stadium you know we would we were doing
this in a respectful way
um but we were making clear the values
that we stand for as a nation and for us
in Wales you know we're the smallest
country represented in this world cup
that's uh that's actually qualified and
it was really important for us to use
our role in the World Cup as a platform
to show what we're all about as a nation
and that's about human rights for
everyone and not excluding the LGBT
community from that so that's partly why
it was so disappointing rather than the
personal intimidation
what exactly did they say to you I'm
just intrigued you know when they
stopped you and you can see the video
there that happening what was the reason
that they gave
Well we'd had a word passed back to us
in the queue that some of our colleagues
from the faw and other fans had had
issues with their rainbow hat so a
couple of us were standing together
sensed that something was likely to
happen but obviously we weren't prepared
to take our hats off you know as I say
it's a important emblem if you like for
our commitment to Human Rights and and
equality for all but when I went through
the security scanners
um and I came through the other end one
of the female security guards pointed to
my hat and said take off and I said why
you know I have to emphasize we've been
really polite in all of this there was
no point at which we tried to seek any
confrontation I asked why and she simply
replied regulation so I asked which
regulation because obviously you know I
work with the faw and I I'm involved
with UEFA so I do know the regulations
um and she she couldn't really answer so
another lady came forward and said the
same take hat off or you can't enter the
stadium and again I asked it why and
they simply came up with word regulation
so I mean I stood my ground I just said
I don't know what you're referring to
but by then a male I think he he was
some kind of security manager uh came
around and and pointed again to the hat
and said if you don't take that off you
don't come in inside the stadium
you say you know you obviously did stand
your ground and you are someone who you
know you're a former Captain you are an
ambassador you're someone in a position
of some Authority but it must have felt
quite intimidating
uh well it wasn't the best experience
I've had of going into a a stadium and
you know I've been as well as being
involved in football I'm a fan first and
foremost you know I've I've been to
Wales game since I was a toddler
um and it's you know it's a pretty
unsavory start to what was the biggest
game in our country's history you know
we haven't been in a World Cup as you
know for 64 years so I was looking
forward to going in with my friends and
my colleagues from the Football
Association was to support uh the the
national team so it wasn't ideal but
there's so much else that I think we
have to stand up for in a in a country
like Qatar you know we know all of us
who are here are horribly compromised by
the political regime here we know that
you know they've been such Dreadful
issues around migrant workers we know
that women don't have basic rights as
they do in the west we know as well that
LGBT people are criminalized and so I
think you know for those of us who live
in countries like Wales where obviously
those rights are protected and promoted
you know it is incumbent on us as well
to standard ground and to show that you
know LGBT rights are human rights and
the other thing I'd say actually is that
you know people have said to me
um I think mostly we've had great
support for our Stan but if anyone was
trying to be critical they've said you
know are you not
disrespecting local cultures and Norms
here but I think there's a really
important point there which is this
isn't a Qatari World Cup this is the
FIFA World Cup in Qatar and FIFA is the
organizing uh body for this and they
assured everyone that that everyone
would be welcome that it was a World Cup
for the whole world whoever they are and
whatever their identity and of course
the advice and guidance around rainbow
symbols uh reflected that so I think you
know given all of that it was really
important that we stood up to some
pretty heavy-handed security within the
stadium
it's interesting you talk about people
making that argument and you know on
this program you know I've asked
government ministers about it and
they've said that it's important for
people to respect the laws in their
words of the host country do you agree
with that assessment or do you think
that the UK government should be a bit
stronger I guess
well it's a very delicate balance isn't
it you know I think there's an issue
over awarding uh major events to
countries that can't guarantee basic
human rights and that's one for FIFA
obviously but I mean we have to live our
values whilst we're here you know and
I've had nothing but support from our
government in Wales and indeed from from
the Welsh public and I think there's
lots of people at home who are trade
unionists who are feminists who are LGBT
uh people or activists or Allies and
they felt very uncomfortable about
coming to Qatar so those of us who are
here here in a work capacity have a duty
I think to speak up for them and to show
that you know that there is a an
alternative
equality if you like in our countries
which I think is really important you
know because otherwise how do we ever
have conversations about change and you
know I'm I don't want to be
disrespectful to anyone in Qatar but I
think the very fact that we've been able
to highlight this issue you know people
Qatar people and other nations have
talked to us as Wales fans wearing our
rainbow hats they've talked to us about
what we're about and what those symbols
represent and in a sense that's what a
major International Sports tournament
has to be about as well because there's
no there's no doubt at all in my mind
you know that it's nonsense to suggest
that politics and Sport are separate
they're not and that's the reason why
the world cup is here in the first place
of course so equally you can't then
remove politics once we come to a state
like Qatar and expect us not to be true
to the values that are important to us
in Wales and and of course in England
and in other countries which have much
more Progressive attitudes to this and
fair play to you as well for you know
doing this interview you're there in
Qatar and you are you know sort of
taking on if you like some of those uh
prejudices by giving us your view as
well and players have been registering
their protests in different ways we've
had some teams for example covering
their mouths to show that they couldn't
stay at what they wanted to but they've
stopped short of you know wearing the
rainbow armband and taking the yellow
card as punishment
do you think there should have been a
bit more I guess coordinated action we
had Greg Dyke on the program earlier he
said that look if people have been a bit
more organized all of the European teams
for example coming together saying that
they would have worn the rainbow armband
then actually
um they'd have just had to swallow it
well I think there's a few things to say
there you know I think it was
fundamentally wrong of FIFA to
intervene in the players environment on
Match day I mean that's unforgivable you
know the players are here to play
football and whatever the issue they
shouldn't be conversations with players
about what they wear on the field of
play on the day of a match or hours
before kickoff which of course is what
FIFA did with England and and indeed
with us in Wales
um I think we'll have to reflect on this
when we get back you know because I know
that Gareth Bale the the Wales Captain
was extremely keen and enthusiastic to
wear the one love arm band you know he
he felt it was an important reflection
of the the stuff that I've been talking
about really what what our nation is all
about but I think you know you have to
recognize as well that FIFA were
threatening Beyond red cards you know
they kept it an open-ended threat from
what I gather that it could be beyond
the yellow card so who knows how that
would have played out and I think that's
fundamentally wrong you know we've put
in the players in a really invidious
position we learned lessons from it
because I think in unity their strength
and the Seven National associations
those who've got Progressive equality
approaches should have probably thought
about a plan b or what might happen
given we hadn't hadn't had a formal
response from FIFA about the one love
Arm bans but you know we will reflect on
that certainly in Wales where these
these matters uh these matters are very
very important to us but but I have to
say you know as a former player myself
on Match day you know the attention of
players should be on the biggest game in
their careers and for those Welsh
players you know they were the first
players to represent Wales in a World
Cup for six decades and I know they
wanted to do their best on equality
issues but it was very very wrong of
FIFA to put them in that position
talking about the biggest game of
people's careers at Wells of course
playing England I'm not going to ask if
you're going to watch the game because I
certainly know the answer to that one
um but do you think whilst I've got a
chance of beating England
well of course we've got a chance
um but we're going to have to play a lot
better than we've played in the first
two games
um I think the fans will they won't be
optimistic but they'll still believe
I've spoken to a lot of my friends who
are here who still think that we can get
a result against England we've got to
Hope of course at the Iran USA game is a
draw then but you know we we haven't
beaten England for a long time so we do
we're do a win but you know make no
mistaking that England are a great team
they've got strength in depth they've
got such quality on the bench and at the
moment we're not firing on on Old
cylinders but but things change very
quickly in football you know if we go
out and put in a performance yes we can
beat them but you know I think from most
Welsh fans perspectives it's the
performance now we've been disappointed
on the pitch for whatever reason and I
think if we can go out and play well and
with real passion and energy against
England I think the result will come but
even if it doesn't come uh the fact the
fans will be proud of the the team and
go home you know happy that we've shown
what we're about out on the world stage
um great thank you so much for being on
the program today you know you've been
such a sort of strong voice for equality
and for you know the values that you
clearly hold very dear as well in Qatar
so thank you